Quanti di voi vorrebbero fare gli
influencer di lavoro
e quanti sono proprio curioso di sapere
che cosa fanno gli influencer di lavoro
Io ho un nipote è un classico esemplare
di generazione z a 11 anni sono alla
chitarra elettrica gioca a Minecraft non
guarda più cartoni animati solo video di
YouTube di gente che gioca Minecraft e
mi ha detto che da grande vuole fare lo
youtuber che io gli ho chiesto perché
anche se guardando negli occhi sua madre
che è mia sorella suonava più come un
perché
E lui mi ha risposto È zia me li voglio
fare come te che ti pagano per leggere i
libri voglio che mi paghino per giocare
a Minecraft
E lì ho capito che c'era un problema
grande problema di comunicazione Cioè
l'influencer non è il ragazzo che passa
il pomeriggio a giocare ai videogiochi E
si riprende per poi mettere i video su
YouTube e svelare trucchi e strategie ma
non è neanche la biondona di turno che
ci fa vedere tutte le decine di scarpe
che ha nella cabina armadio quello
dell'influencer è un lavoro e da un
preadolescente di 11 anni con la sua
innocenza posso anche aspettarmi che non
sia proprio chiarissimo questo concetto
però se anche i giornali non ci fanno
anche i giornali non ci fanno chiarezza
perché definiscono Tommaso Mazzanti il
titolare di all'antico Vinaio come
l'influencer che fattura 23 milioni di
euro vendendo le sue schiacciate capite
bene che è normale che non sia così
chiaro che cosa fa un influencer e
Tommaso Mazzanti ci ha tenuto a
precisare che non è un influencer lui è
un imprenditore che quel fatturato l'ha
ottenuto sgobbando dalla mattina alla
sera nei suoi locali con la sua attività
Ma quindi che cos'è l'influenza Chi è
che cosa fa facciamo chiarezza e per
fare chiarezza meglio di questa location
per parlare di comunicazione dobbiamo
partire dalle definizioni e quindi
vedere che cosa vuol dire influencer è
un personaggio molto conosciuto nei
social network in generale nei media che
ha il potere un po' come i supereroi di
influenzare delle un determinato
pubblico quindi delle persone nelle loro
scelte nei loro comportamenti
Alcuni dicono che anch'io sono un
influencer
Scusate sono andata
E perché dieci anni fa circa ho aperto
il mio blog di libri l'angolo dei libri
e consiglio attraverso le recensioni e i
libri che leggo quali sono quelli che mi
sono piaciuti di più sperando di
convincere qualcuno a leggerli E che
altrettanto siano piaciuti anche a loro
in realtà è nato tutto molto per gioco
un'amica avvenuta a casa mia visto la
mia libreria che è quella che vedete
nella foto ho detto oh mamma quanti
libri Io sono anni che non leggo Dammi
un libro che così magari mi torna la
voglia uno fai Dagliene uno troppi E
allora sì tre minimo per partire di tre
generi completamente diversi così che
potesse trovare il suo genere preferito
e sapete com'è andata a finire
non gliene è piaciuto neanche uno
Però è stato un successo comunque perché
lei ha capito cosa non le piaceva e ha
detto Ok Cerchiamo dell'altro e poi ha
trovato la sua strada e si è
riappassionata alla lettura e io ho
avuto l'illuminazione ho capito che con
lei non era andata bene ma se fossi
davvero riuscita a riavvicinare qualcuno
alla lettura a riaccendere la fiamma
della passione per i libri consigliando
semplicemente quello che era piaciuto a
me che potrebbe piacere anche a voi e da
lì è nato il blog e sembra che io ci sia
riuscita perché in qualche modo insomma
nel 2019 Sono arrivata a seconda in
macchia nera Words che sono un po' gli
Oscar della rete perché si occupa di
Digital come miglior sito letterario
quindi per Qualcuno aveva funzionato i
miei consigli avevano funzionato e tra
pagina Facebook profilo Instagram sito
blog newsletter ho una follower base si
dice in gergo del marketing di più di
50.000 persone quindi o i numeri per
poter essere chiamata influencer i
numeri perché ci servono dei numeri
e pensando a cosa potevo raccontarvi in
questo Talk ho detto beh racconto la mia
esperienza perché se ci sono riuscita io
nel mio piccolo con la mia passione per
la lettura Secondo me potete riuscirci
benissimo anche voi e quindi ho pensato
solo per voi 100 poco più di rivelarvi
oggi la Formula per diventare influencer
così lo potete fare anche voi subito da
stasera domani a casa pronti quindi
Smartphone alla mano pronti a
screenshotttare perché la formula
apparirà qui su
Eccola qua
è semplice Un po' di post per un po' di
giorni e puff arrivano i follower e la
fama è successo la visibilità la
notorietà
troppo semplice di te
andiamo a vedere i singoli elementi di
questa equazione Perché ognuno nasconde
poi qualcosa partiamo da i post Quanti
post servono per diventare influencer
c'è un numero un X Allora io sul mio
profilo Instagram ne Ho circa 1.300
qualcosa meno e ho 38 mila follower
Quindi potrebbe già essere
un'indicazione Se però pensiamo a Chiara
Ferragni lei ne ha 16.500 di post e ha
più di 26 27 milioni di follower poi il
dato si aggiorna talmente velocemente
che le slide non ci stanno dietro e
Amadeus Però ne ha solo 17 di post e ha
già un milione e 800 mila follower
Quindi no non sono degli esempi che
vanno bene cambiamo esempio
ClioMakeUp ClioMakeUp la conosciamo
tutti ha un'azienda fattura più di 10
milioni di euro vendendo i suoi
cosmetici però non so se tutti lo sanno
ma ha iniziato come youtuber e sul suo
canale YouTube del 2008 quando l'ha
aperto ad oggi ha più di mille video
mille video che se facciamo proprio una
media molto spannometrica durano circa
20 minuti qualcuno più qualcuno meno
però non le Ci sono voluti 20 minuti per
fare un video perché tra pensa fai lo
storyboard registra poi fai un po' di
editing e qualche taglio perché qualcosa
da correggere c'è sempre la grafica per
la copertina sponsorizzarlo sugli altri
social Insomma diciamo che in una
giornata lavorativa Canonica visto che
di lavoro parliamo di 8 ore riuscirà a
produrre dando le fiducia mediamente dai
due ai tre video quindi un bel po' di
video un bel po' di contenuti Ma a
proposito di tempo per quanti giorni poi
devo continuare a farsi video perché
prima di diventare influencer mi ci
vorrà un po' di tempo quanto tempo
quanti giorni facciamo un altro esempio
e parliamo di Salvatore Aranzulla tutti
conosciamo tutti gli dobbiamo più di un
caffè perché c'è sicuramente salvato la
vita più di una volta vero è Salvatore
aranzu sul blog di Tecnologia con più di
15.000 articoli se pensiamo che potrebbe
averne scritto uno al giorno per
arrivare qui i numeri gli si sarebbero
voluti tipo 41 anni lavorando tutti i
giorni pubblicando un contenuto ogni
giorno sabato domenica e festivi
compresi Considerando che Aranzulla di
anni ne ha 32 no due post al giorno
facciamo così dai sì potrebbe essere una
ventina d'anni iniziato molto giovane sì
ci sta poi Considerate che Aranzulla non
è da solo adesso c'è un team di persone
che scrivono per lui quindi Insomma ci
sta però parliamo Comunque di mesi non
certo giorni in settimane per arrivare
al traguardo Che poi il traguardo qual è
È quello sono i follower i follower Ma
che poi quei foller cosa ci facciamo coi
follower mica ci paghiamo la spesa coi
follower non è una cripto valuta che in
un qualche metaverso nascosto ha un
valore è un numero un numero che le
stesse piattaforme Social chiamano
Vanity metric cioè metri quello della
vanità che mi serve solo per dire Ah io
c'ho più follower di te e quindi è un
numero che serve poco e poi è un numero
che non rappresenta il numero effettivo
di persone che vedono i vostri contenuti
perché li subentra un'altra cosa
subentra la copertura organica la
copertura organica è il numero di
persone che effettivamente vede un
contenuto quando voi lo pubblicate ad
esempio sui social e per restare su
Instagram quella di Instagram va dal 2
al 5% quando siamo fortunati Questo vuol
dire Scusate nel frattempo che non è se
siete riusciti ad arrivare a 100
follower sgomitando convincendo amici
parenti cugini zii il tutto il vicinato
a seguirvi e siete arrivati a 100
follower quando pubblicate il vostro
contenuto lo vedono in cinque
e c'è una brutta notizia ovviamente che
più cresce il numero di follower più si
abbassa la percentuale Quindi quando
arrivate a 200 follower il contenuto lo
vedono in otto
e quando arrivati a 300 follower il
contenuto lo vedono in 11 qui sempre
peggio quindi capite che ci vogliono
davvero decine centinaia e migliaia di
follower per poter tenere sulla Baracca
Ok per poter essere considerati degli
influencer e poi c'è un'altra domanda
che dovete farvi ma questo pubblico che
cosa gli facciamo fare cioè la community
che dobbiamo costruirci ha bisogno di
interagire deve lasciare dei commenti
dei mi piace condividere i nostri post
farli girare per così Noi aumentiamo il
nostro successo e quindi ha bisogno di
contenuti interessanti ma interessanti
non per voi che li pubblicate quindi non
è che Ah vabbè Oggi faccio la storia se
dico cosa mangerò stasera per cena dove
vado in vacanza quest'estate no
contenuti interessanti per il vostro
pubblico Perché le persone sono
interessate a quello che dite se dite
qualcosa che per loro è interessante e
quindi dovete fare quello che nel
marketing si chiama lo studio del target
e andare a capire che cosa cercano le
persone su Google ad esempio Quali sono
i loro bisogni le loro necessità
Aranzulla ha fatto successo così cioè sa
che abbiamo determinati problemi che
siamo un po' indietro con la tecnologia
E ci aiuta rispondendo alle nostre
domande e dobbiamo capire che cosa gli
piace guardare sui social che cosa sono
i contenuti che apprezzano di più e
dobbiamo capire effettivamente cosa gli
interessa e produrre contenuti che per
loro siano interessanti Google Ogni anno
lancia un report con le parole più
cercate sul motore di ricerca queste
sono quelle del 2022 alcune facilmente
intuibili visti gli ultimi accadimenti
altre magari un po' meno ma non c'è solo
Google ci sono delle piattaforme che ci
permettono di capire cosa le persone
cercano online e quello che magari non
sapete Ma che vi svelo io è che in
un'ora 10 volte all'ora viene cercata
l'espressione Come guadagnare online
cercata 6.600 volte al mese Questo per
il discorso che facevamo prima che c'è
un po' questa convinzione che il content
Creator l'influencer siano quei lavori
con poca fatica e tanto successo
in realtà non è proprio così
mi sentirei di aggiungere qualche altra
piccola variabile nella formuletta che
vi ho mostrato prima perché questo
lavoro perché chiamiamolo per quello che
è un lavoro richiede anche altre cose
richiede
competenza dobbiamo sapere quello di cui
parliamo Non è che ClioMakeUp si è
svegliata un giorno ha detto beh aspetta
mi faccio un video Finché mi provo
questo rossetto ClioMakeUp è un'amica
parti sta studiando per fare questo
lavoro lo fa tuttora e ha deciso di
condividere parte del suo sapere con la
sua Community
Aranzulla è un Nerd che da quando è nato
da quando ha conoscenza Continua a
studiare a documentarsi a capire come
funzionano i dispositivi Chiara Ferragni
Vabbè avete capito no bisogna sapere le
cose bisogna avere una certa con
padronanza e competenza quindi Caro
nipote che un giorno mi riguarderai c'è
da studiare anche per fare lo youtuber
da lì non ci piove e poi serve tanta
pazienza perché se vi esponete online
dovete essere preparati ad accedere
critiche commenti non richiesti A volte
anche la visita di qualche hater che vi
disturba e vi intasa il profilo di
spam e altre cose poco piacevoli Quindi
se già non è che siete proprio delle
persone super pazienti e magari vi
Accendete facilmente Ecco Magari
potreste partire un po' svantaggiati in
questo lavoro altra cosa importantissima
è l'originalità
c'è gente che ha fatto successo sui
social facendo dei gesti mostrando i
piedi su all'infanzia Io lo so che voi
vi chiedete come Fan come hanno fatto Me
lo chiedo anch'io Ma al di là di quello
ci sono riusciti basta Cioè se lo
facciamo anche noi siamo solamente le
brutte copie di qualcosa di già visto
quindi o ci facciamo venire quell'idea
originale che ci fa ricordare che ci fa
diventare famosi oppure cerchiamo di
prendere qualcosa che già c'è e di
personalizzarlo di renderlo unico di
renderlo nostro e poi serve un minimo di
investimenti se siete online e volete
avere una presenza online vi serve un
logo una Visual identity l'euro mi
servono un immagine coordinata e poi vi
serve un sito web
E perché mica vorrete puntare solo sui
social che quelli domani chiudono e voi
rimanete a piedi vi serve anche un sito
web e poi vi serve un po' di
attrezzatura uno smartphone di ultima
generazione una videocamera un microfono
una Ring Light Insomma 5.000 euro per
partire secondo me vi servono tutti e
poi tenete conto anche di un piccolo
gruzzoletto con cui mantenervi per non è
che a partite a bomba e aziende che vi
pagano per fare i contenuti all'inizio
farete contenuti Grazie quindi un'altra
fonte di sostentamento la dovete avere
quindi capite che con tutti questi
elementi la formula iniziale che era
forse un po' troppo semplice si va a
complicare e diventa una cosa un po' più
articolata un po' più impegnativa direi
e c'è una Però un'altra brutta notizia e
non vorrei essere anche la prima
portatrice di brutta e notizie Ma la
brutte notizie è che non è che basta
applicare la formula e tac tutti
influences magari non sarei qua forse
può andare bene oppure no c'è il solito
classico rischio di impresa Ok quindi ci
si prova e poi si vede come va E vorrei
adesso ritornare per chiudere alla
domanda iniziale quindi Quanti sono
ancora convinti di voler fare gli
influencer di lavoro adesso che abbiamo
un po' capito come funziona
Però un piccolo giochetto un esercizio
per voi perché magari Dai vi faccio
tornare la voglia non volevo proprio
distruggere le vostre aspettative il
gioco e questo visto che è l'edizione
dei Lab ho pensato che anche per tutti
voi c'era un piccolo compito per casa e
domani che è domenica vi trovate con gli
amici con i parenti Scegliete 10 persone
e Provate a convincerla a influenzarle a
leggere non so l'ultimo libro che vi è
piaciuto o a comprare quel prodotto che
secondo voi merita o ad andare a cena in
quel ristorante perché lì Assolutamente
si mangia bene Beh se riuscite a
influenzare almeno 7 persone su 10
allora Siete sulla buona strada per
diventare degli influencer